often struggle with the question is
sexuality a part of human nature
if it is there's something fundamentally
wrong with me
[Music]
I fell in love with my best friend she
gave me a reason to wake up when things
got hard she's straight I'm the weird
gay girl
I'm a transgender girl who still
sometimes fantasizes about having sex as
a gay man
I'm transgender I haven't come out
because my family doesn't support the
community at all
I feel more judgement from the LGBT
community than I do from straight people
and it makes me heartbroken it's sad
because we're all going through the same
thing so you would think that that would
be a place to find support but it's it's
not always yeah that's sad
when I built up the courage to come out
to my family last week my father was
dead silent no reaction my mom put her
hand on his arm to comfort him
as if he needed help to get through this
I tried to act like it didn't affect me
but I'm ashamed that it did
I pretended to be straight with most
people so they don't ask questions about
my sexuality or ignore it altogether I'm
a 15 year old girl for a long time I've
known that I'm bisexual but I've never
told anyone it scares me that my family
or friends won't love me the same
once they find out I live in a country
where being a homosexual is a crime no
one in my family or my friends knows
about me I'm afraid if someone figures
out they will kill me just like having
the fear that you might be killed
because of the person you love
it's horrible no one should ever go
through that my grandfather is the only
one in my family that doesn't know I'm
gay I'm a beautiful
gay son and I look back and I'm so
hoping that he felt like he could come
out to us and feel safe and feel loved
but I would say to the person who wrote
this me be you you have to come out and
be you come out to safe people first and
then I would just tell me you can't lose
hope you have to keep looking for those
friends and I think sometimes friends
come from unexpected places regardless
of whether they're gay or straight you
always do have to accept yourself cuz by
doing that nothing can break you from
there
just keep your head up hey guys Jason
from Jubilee here thank you so much for
watching another episode of seeking
secrets and we want to say a big shout
out to our sponsors simple habit simple
habit is an incredible mental wellness
app that has all these different guided
meditations and therapies I find that I
love using simple habit before work or
if I'm really really stressed the night
before a big meeting these are all
different things and you can actually
find specific meditations on for all of
our viewers we have a special link with
that link you actually get seven days a
free premium content download it give it
a shot I've fall in love with it I think
you guys will too
thank you guys once again for watching
and we'll see you guys next time